so glad that you're here with us today
uh you and i have been friends for a
long time that's correct um most the
people that i talk to on this podcast
are not my friends they're not your
friends or they're pretending to be your
friend
many people in this town to make it in
the business to progress to the next
level no one
uh climbs the showbiz ladder until
they've made friends with one another
yeah and uh but you and i have known
each other for a really long time many
many years many people say
your whole musical style was sort of
based
on
what am i doing here
you're lying people just lie just lying
out lying
as a child watch me on late night and
then you said i could maybe uh use his
vocal rhythm no no no never uh guitar
solo as an example of what not to do
yeah okay all right all right well maybe
i went too far and i i do apologize
um no uh you are uh
with so many people like like sona yeah
you only think i'm cool because i know
that's actually that's the only reason
you think i'm cool yeah yeah i mean
think about your other friends i love
them but yeah they're not japanese it's
dork central yeah and then there's
then there is
this guy wrote a james bond theme song i
know and you know him i know i know and
the and you are of course the james bond
huge fan aficionado of all time and of
that movie oh yeah
that's one of the most divisive it is
things i've been a part of that song why
is that i mean it's it's to this day
it's
it's the straight across the board
people say oh you love her you hated
something that song is there are people
who hate it so much and people who love
it so much
nowhere in the middle it's so strange
that's like the movie itself i think i
think yeah so the movie comes along with
what people think of it but but
bomb themes in britain for example are
like that's com consistent coffee
breakfast conversation you know like
what's your favorite bond so it's almost
like who you are as a person like you
you relate to which song it means
something to you it's really i mean it's
great company to be in when you think
about some of the iconic bonds oh yeah
even what's your favorite bond song of
all time there's a uh
the one i think i'm drawn to is tom
jones's thunderball
yeah
and i don't know if you know this but
johnny cash recorded an attempt ethan
this is crazy this i heard he just came
up on the jeff goldblum episode he was
saying how much he loved thunderball and
i was talking about this johnny cash
system
yeah it was while he was feeling uh all
of our faces with his tentacles
oh oh oh oh yes yes yes johnny cash um
no so he wrote one he wanted to you know
johnny cash wanted to have recorded a
bond song just didn't make it it didn't
make it yeah unsolicited submission
yeah i got in because amy winehouse
wasn't showing up to the sessions wasn't
or wasn't delivering
uh the song that they were asking her to
do
so it was we're running out of time we
need somebody else to do it and i
thought oh this is great because now i'm
going to get away with murder
i'm going to put things in this song
they would never approve of this right
this section and all that and that
happened it got to be um
the music director was not down with and
he was trying to kind of convince me to
turn into a ballad or something like
that and
you know um
it got interesting it was like i i don't
i we're going on tour i don't have time
i really can't get in there knowing full
well i i'm like i'm well i totally have
time to fix it if i want it's so funny
my favorite move is i'm sorry i can't
but i don't have time and then that
person sees you at a leisurely lunch
two hours later and you're clearly doing
nothing
one of my favorite moves and you know
who did it to me once adam west really
adam west when when robert smigiel and i
were working on this tv project we
wanted to bring adam west back to tv and
we were working on this kooky project
called look well and we had this
audition with him with the network and
they said yes we're going to bring adam
west back to tv you guys can make this
pilot we were so excited and we said to
him
hey do you want to uh
go out and get dinner with anyone i'd
love to gentlemen but i'm
very busy i have big plans tonight we're
like oh okay mr west no problem and then
robert and i went down to the hotel to
get dinner and we saw him sitting alone
alone
alone batman would rather sit alone
and
he saw us and gave like a little nod he
wasn't even ashamed
you didn't think i'd really have dinner
with you did you
mr wayne
we understand